this means we are inching ever closer to
the U.S no longer having the reserve
currency and you know what that means
that means all of you at home you're
going to see your standard of living
drop dramatically and therein lies the
double double-edged sword when it comes
to International Politics the United
States does not export enough we export
culture movies music sure but other
countries can do that other countries
can export a lot of stuff
so what do we really provide to be
honest military might when we want oil
we print the dollars we buy the oil when
any other country wants oil they need to
buy dollars from us from us first with
this deal from bricks that basically
shuts down our International Ponzi
scheme or whatever you want to call it
and then all of a sudden we have nothing
to trade what will the U.S trade for
brics currency that's the big question
what are we manufacturing what are we
exporting that bricks would want so that
they would give us gold back currency
that we could use to buy oil